until one has loved an animal wrote the
journalist and author Anatole France a
part of one's soul remains unawakened
there is no evidence
Donald Trump has ever loved an animal if
Trump has ever in his life had a pet
wrote Gayle Collins of the New York
Times his campaign doesn't know about it
there's some question in fact about
whether he's ever even had an animal
friend in fact none of the books about
Trump including his own seemed to refer
to a pet dog the co-author or
ghostwriter of the art of the deal Tony
Schwartz told me he has never heard
Trump reference a pet as adult or child
google it fact check it do a Nexus Lexus
search on it you come up blank save for
an apocryphal story about him tweeting
asking for prayers for a Labrador named
Spinney there were no tweets no
entreaties and for all we can determine
no Spinney a man running to lead a
nation of 324 million people and while
were added 78 million dogs and as many
cats or more and there are solid reasons
to believe he has never had a dog never
had a dog but it's worse than just that
isn't it July 2015
I heard that sleepy eyes Chuck Todd will
be fired like a dog October 2015
Wow great news I hear a hurricane in a
red state was fired like a dog december
glenn beck got fired like a dog this
january union leader refuses to comment
as to why they were kicked out of the
ABC News debate like a dog 12 days later
brent bozell one of the National Review
lightweights came to my office begging
for money like a dog huh was the last
time you saw dog begging for money in an
office February well was Ted Cruz
disloyal to his very capable director of
communication used him as a scapegoat
fired like a dog
March Eric Erickson again got fired like
a dog from red state eleven days after
that david gregory got thrown off TV by
NBC fired like a dog june mit romney had
his chance to beat a failed president
but he choked like a dog huh the hell's
wrong with this guy fired like a dog
have you ever fired a dog he's also said
that Egyptian President Mubarak was
dropped like a dog
that Reverend Wright was dumped like a
dog that Mark Cuban was thrown off
television like a dog that Kristen
Stewart cheated on Robert Pattinson like
a dog and worst of all he said that
during a Republican debate he saw
Senator Marco Rubio sweating like a dog
dogs don't sweat I mean in theory they
could get fired or cheat on or beg for
money or get dropped dumped kick table
thrown off television but they
physically can't sweat Donald Trump has
no understanding of this no evidence
he's ever had a dog no evidence he
understands even the kinds of basics
that people who don't have dogs still
know about dogs what the hell is he from
Mars look until four years ago last week
I had never had a dog allergies as a kid
never at home as an adult
never thought myself mature enough to
assume the responsibility and then it
happened
and it didn't change me much I only got
one more dog and got two other dogs for
my girlfriend's parents and started
working with a rescue shelter for
injured and sick dogs and started giving
out dog books for Christmas and saw that
most of human behavior was easily
explained by watching dogs and called
all my dog world friends from before I
was blessed and asked why didn't you
tell me and I realized that dogs
explained enough of the meaning of life
that you don't need to know any of the
other possible meanings of life
no biggie I was just born again and
Donald Trump no dog as Anatole France
said part of his soul unawakened even so
this was still just philosophy and then
the Trump campaign put out and almost as
quickly pulled back a proposal to
eliminate what it called the FDA food
police citing as one of its supposed
government overreaches that it quote
even dictates the nutritional content of
dog food well it does dictate the
nutritional content of dog food it
dictates the nutritional content of dog
food so the dog food does not kill the
dogs as The Daily Beast reported in the
last year 11 of the 23 FDA pet food
recalls were to remove poisoned pet food
from shelves to
save dogs lives and Donald Trump who
tweets fired like a dog cheated on like
a dog begged for money like a dog and
all the other insults as he's go to
insult as if being a dog were somehow a
bad thing
Donald Trump has given a hint that if
elected he would protect a business
man's right to poison dogs maybe your
dogs maybe mine maybe any of the other
78 million because you know profits hey
Don [ __ ] you that's the closure I'm
Keith Olbermann watch this space